gera que c'est ce goût pour les cultures
parfois lointaines on connaît son
attachement et sa connaissance très fine
de du patrimoine asiatique de l'extrême
orient
mais il aimait aussi beaucoup l'afrique
écouter cette confidence de jean paul
delevoye s'est aujourd'hui l'homme qui
est chargé des retraites de la réforme
des retraites mais il a aussi été un
proche collaborateur de jacques chirac
car n'oublions jamais cette dimension
d'une extraordinaire culture des peuples
les identités surtout la résonance
africaine s'est pas neutre quand vous
allez en afrique les chauffeurs de taxi
vous dise la france ah oui chirac
voilà et puis c'est jacques chirac qui
avait aussi parfois des positions qu'on
appellerait peut-être tiers-mondiste
avec un discours assez critique sur la
colonisation par exemple celles du
portugal et de l'espagne
vis-à-vis de l'amérique celle aussi de
lattre l'élimination des indiens
d'amérique écouter cet autre souvenir de
jean paul delevoye vous un repas
officiel avec le président mexicain ont
parlé du teide génocide etc
il lisait on entend des deux plus grands
jets le site c'est celui des amérindiens
et il a raconté l'histoire du mexique
est la limite presque mieux que ne le
rencontrer le président mexicain
les aztèques était extrêmement pacifique
qui ne faisait aucun sacrifice humain
c'est être excessif
est ce qu'il y avait une forme de de
repentance comme on dit aujourd'hui dans
ce dans ses convictions de jacques
chirac est en berne à deux est auto
flagellation de de l'occidental européen
de ge et le plutôt le sentiment qu'on
est en face d'hommes politiques qui
n'avaient pas comme principal objectif
de défendre le bien commun du corps
social dont ils ont la responsabilité
mais de défendre des valeurs abstraites
voilà et donc par conséquent
effectivement les français auraient la
nostalgie d'un président de la
république qui était extrêmement
sympathique ap laurie quand il faisait
campagne mais qui par ailleurs a
contribué très lourdement par le
regroupement familial à détruire la
cohésion du corps social
donc pour moi et fait compter dans ce
cas économique c'était de dire des
capitaux sorte de la france et des
autres est important et on est en train
de créer un espèce d'aspiration
économique et donc chirac à l'époque
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas appris la
décision du regroupement familial sur
des arguments purement économique en
disant exaucer ses problèmes
cette expression série d'ennemis d'un
côté les différences entre lui
mitterrand et ceux qui l'ont suivi c'est
que jacques chirac il a pris conscience
à un moment qui avait pas d'intégration
qu'il fallait travailler pour
l'intégration ce qui n'a pas été le cas
deux mitterrand parce que c'est un sacré
sig cirque dans les banlieues ce qui n'a
pas été le cas de ses successeurs qu'on
préférait laisser tomber les valeurs et
les principes républicains pour
finalement accepter la montée du
communautarisme et les résultats qu'on
voit aujourd'hui donc il faut quand même
lui reconnaître ça et arrêtez d'en faire
quelqu'un qui a fait exploser
l'immigration je veux bien entendre ça
mais en réalité l'immigration
aujourd'hui elle est tout à fait
comparable et non seulement elle n'est
pas maîtrisée mais en plus les principes
qui vont derrière ne sont plus du tout
imposé donc là dessus il faut quand même
reconnaître une chose c'est que ses
valeurs elle n'était pas évanescente ses
valeurs elle était concrètes chez lui et
c'est à mon avis la raison pour laquelle
il était tellement attaché aux peuples
africains aux peuples asiatiques parce
que je rappelle que il s'est battu aussi
pour les boat people c'est parce que
justement il avait des valeurs
humanistes et que pour lui et il y avait
une chose qui était important de cette
et l'être humain voilà mais pas les
enfants à naître cercle la même année en
1975 la loi veil qui conduit à lui qui
des deux cent mille enfants à naître par
an et par ailleurs l'anglo familiale
donc la substitution mais il est
incapable de dire à deng xiaoping non
vous vous trompez il n'y a pas eu 12 en
stock et donc mais quand même par
rapport à ça je crois que c'est
important de dire parce que chirac qui
était un homme politique n'était pas un
perdreau de l'année
ne pensez pas que cette ses valeurs
culturelles lui servirait pour sa
conquête du national d'aller expliquer
au peuple français qui était en train de
se redéfinir qu'il était un grand
spécialiste de l'art africain
je suis pas persuadé que ça lui aurait
servi en revanche d'expliquer qu'on
était un spécialiste de stendhal quand
on était mitterrand et bien vis-à-vis de
l' intelligence et vis-à-vis d'une
certaine pensée germanopratine
politiquement sache ça a servi à amitié
juste un exemple ce matin sur une grande
radio nationale madame vous rappelle ce
qu'a fait chirac pour le pour le bénin
et la question de la journaliste sans
vraiment vouloir le faire elle dit mais
vous pensez pas qu'ils plaçaient les
cultures au dessus de la culture
occidentale et lui dit vous n'avez pas
compris
justement chirac voyait il n'y avait pas
de hiérarchie dans les cultures et sa
politiquement pour lui c'était
invendables donc ces choses là
évidemment il les a masqué parce qu'il
savait très bien la difficulté déjà
qu'il avait à vendre cette espèce de
deux grands gars virevoltant agitée
comme disait jusqu alors l ai expliqué
que les valeurs du monde pouvait se
trouver ailleurs et notamment dans les
cultures africaines
rappelez-vous le pataquès en france
quand sylvain gouguenheim a expliqué que
la culture européenne avait été traduit
par des traducteurs islamique
rappelez vous alors si chirac avait
commencé a expliqué que c'était un grand
spécialiste de samé et sa carrière
politique aurait été je pense
complètement vidé de son essence et il
avait déjà suffisamment de difficultés à
faire adhérer à tous les leaders
politiques pour progresser en tout cas
ce qui est vrai c'est que jacques chirac
semblaient plus intéressés par ces
cultures lointaines peut-être que tout
simplement par l'histoire de son propre
pays mais à paris l'assaut de répéter ce
témoignage de philippe de villiers
recueilli par le figaro live hier comme
ça va assez vite je vous donne la
punchline tout de suite
il pensait jacques chirac l'histoire je
m'en fous alors en fait on le retrouvera
peut-être tout à l'heure cette phrase
moi l'histoire je m'en fous nous a
expliqué philippe de villiers hier on
écoute tout de suite et ce n'était pas
son truc
le cri non plus il préférait lorient
alors l'occident non plus n'était pas
son truc il préférait dorion adrien
matou est ce que c'est un mauvais procès
ou est ce qu'on peut dire parce que
c'est un fait que jacques chirac montre
une attention très forte à ses cultures
par exemple orientale et que dans le
même temps il s'opposait à ce que on
mentionne les racines chrétiennes de
l'europe dans la constitution européenne
comme si il y avait une préférence pour
le pour le lointain je suis pas d'accord
avec ça parce que je j'ai du mal à
saisir cette idée de de compétition
entre les cultures comme si si l'on
appréciait si l'on s'intéressait plus à
une culture asiatique ou africaine
ça signifie qu'on retirait autant de sa
connaissance de la culture française il
ne me semble pas que jacques chirac
était quelqu'un de totalement inculte ou
de mes prisons de la culture française
d'ailleurs quand on parle de alors vous
vous dites loin du terroir mais
justement au contraire il était connu
pour être quelqu'un qui aimait le
terroir qui connaissait les régions
françaises peuvent alors c'est peut-être
pas la grande culture leur academical
oui mais ça montre bien que ça ne
diminue pas on ne diminue pas son amour
de la france
en s'intéressant ou en même en
appréciant les cultures d'autres pays
même si je suis pas dans le relativisme
absolu mais je perdrais mon c'est un
mauvais procès que l'on puisse
intéresser y avoir des bébés et même des
connaissances scientifiques sur des
cultures étrangères s'est parfaitement
honorable et recommandable
la question c'est de savoir est ce que
quand il prend des décisions politiques
lorsqu'il fait des choix politiques
est-ce que et alors c'est là où je suis
extrêmement choquée est ce que oui
la culture qui est la sienne et dont il
a la responsabilité politique doit avoir
la priorité sur d'autres c'est ça la
question sorte nationale naturellement
je prends un exemple justement je ne
pense pas du tout que jacques chirac ait
abaissé la culture française ou abaisser
la france en reconnaissant la
responsabilité du gouvernement français
dans la rafle du vel d'hiv à imiter la
france il ya pas dix le régime c'est ça
la différence
oui mais quel crime horrible sont
élevées du régime s'est dès lors qu de
l'état français je ne pense pas du tout
qu'il est parce qu on parle beaucoup de
repentance etc alors certes il faut il
faut pas être dans leur repentance
perpétuelle comme si la france était un
pays abominable qui n'a fait que du mal
mais le fait de regarder son histoire
dans les yeux c'est pas forcément la
déception juste parce que l'internaute
soit pas forcément en tête
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le discours
du vel d'hiv où jacques chirac président
de la république depuis peu reconnaît la
culpabilité de la france dans la
déportation des juifs et pas seulement
du régime de vichy ce qui était jusque
là la version officielle entre
guillemets voulue par de gaulle par
mitterrand en dix ans la vraie france
elle était à londres et elle n'était pas
à vichy la culture il a bien vu que ça
n'avait pas servi pompidou et comme
c'était un profit de lien n'était pas
spécialement beau ici là unifier la
famille gaulliste mais il est avant tout
profit de liens la culture politiquement
quand vous êtes conseiller vous l'avez
dit par marie france garaud par juillet
vous faites des analyses comparatives la
culture c'était mitterrand pour un
chiraquie qui était ce qu'il était il
fallait surtout pas les est le
contre-exemple à paris la politique
culturelle de jacques chirac à paris
mais elle est louée par tout le monde
le châtelet le musée de la poésie il a
été un fervent défenseur d'une culture
traditionnelle française qu'on adore à
paris politiquement pour lui au national
ça n'était absolument pas son sujet il
faut vraiment faire le distinguo entre
cette espèce de forme de culture
snobinarde et puis la culture oui parce
qu'il ya un certain snobisme avec cette
culture de centre-ville et parisien lui
ce qu'il apportait à mon sens c'est
beaucoup plus fort c'est à dire qu'il a
été capable d'exporter la culture
française et la culture ça passe par
quoi ça passe effectivement par une
certaine forme d'art mais ça passe aussi
par l'art culinaire par nos traditions
par les produits qu'on est capable de
fabriquer qui finalement rentrer dans
notre adn parce que quand on a une belle
vache salers ou un bon frau
âge du cantal et bien en réalité on vend
quelque chose qui est unique au monde et
que ben on est les seuls à savoir
fabriquer donc pour moi ça ça fait
partie aussi de la culture de l'identité
française
et pour le coup ça a été le meilleur
voyageur de commerce le contenu
connaître je vous livre cette remarque
de philippe même si c'est pas l'objet
immédiate de discussion score
intéressant
en fait les trahisons dont il a été
l'objet le rendre sympathique
c'est vrai que c'était par exemple été
le cas en 1995 lorsque on le donnait
perdant face à edouard balladur dans la
course à l'elysée intéressons-nous si
vous le voulez bien une autre facette de
la vie de jacques chirac